Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Pop-Tarts
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Pop-Tarts come in
one main size, an eight-pack.
You might also be able
to find a 36-pack online,
but these seem more
geared towards retailers
rather than consumers,
so for the purposes of "Food
Wars," we're not counting them.
In the US, our Pop-Tarts
come in seven size varieties.
Down here with the two-pack; eight-pack;
12-pack; 16-pack, the value pack;
32-pack, the family pack,
I don't know if you can see
it says "family" on there;
and the biggest amount, the 48-pack.
They probably also come in one box.
That means our biggest Pop-Tart
variety is 33.3% bigger
than what you can get in the UK.
But are the Pop-Tarts the
same size in both countries?
Let's measure them to find out.
So, our UK Pop-Tart was 8 centimeters wide
and 11 centimeters long,
for a surface area of
88 centimeters squared.
We will do the same.
3 by 4.
And of course, we're going to weigh it.
Joe: And a Pop-Tart in
the US weighs 48 grams.
Harry: Our UK Pop-Tart
was bang on 50 grams,
which I think is actually slightly more
than it's supposed to weigh.
Kellogg's woke up feeling
a little generous today.
"But what about the
pastry-to-filling ratio?"
I hear you cry.
Well, don't worry, we're
going to look at that too.
You can sort of chisel
off layers of pastry.
I mean, there's really
not much jam in there.
That's a very thin layer
of jam right there.
I think we might have to abandon this.
It's gone real bad.
So, unfortunately, we had
to abandon the scrape test
because that was not working.
Joe, if you pulled that
off, you're a genius.
I don't know how you've done it.
However, on the back of
the box of the Pop-Tarts,
it says that the fruit
filling should be 34%
of the Pop-Tart by weight.
If our maths are correct,
this was a 50-gram Pop-Tart.
34% of that should be 17 grams of jam.
Joe: Yeah, all right.
Hot! Hot! Hot!
Hot. Ow! Mm!
Ow. Mm!
I'm wiping it on here. Right?
We'll round up to 10 grams.
So that is this percentage of jam.
Here's all the Pop-Tarts
you can get in the US
you can't get in the UK.
And here are all the Pop-Tarts from the UK
that you can't find in the US.
Yes, it's just the one.
[laughing]
We got all of them.
Wanted to get this out
of the way real quick.
There are currently two
limited-edition Pop-Tarts
out right now, the red,
white, and blueberry
and the frosted strawberry throwback.
I went to Walmart. The guy
said they didn't have them.
Also, newer ones,
there is an Apple Jacks
frosted apple cinnamon one,
which is supposed to be
delivered to my house tomorrow.
I'm sorry.
But one new one we do have
is frosted banana bread,
which is ... looks like a Pop-Tart.
Gave us some extra frosting up top there.
Yeah, it tastes like banana bread.
Actually, it's very good.
You can only find three Pop-Tart varieties
on sale in the UK, including
strawberry sensation,
frosted chocotastic, and hot fudge sundae.
These two you can also find in the US,
so they're not exclusives,
but this one is. The frosted chocotastic.
While it has its own name, it
does seem a little bit similar
to the US chocolate fudge one,
so we'll take it out and have a look.
So, this is a UK frosted
chocotastic Pop-Tart.
It's got the chocolate icing,
the pastry itself is chocolate-flavored,
and it's got these little
flecks of white stuff on it.
Ambitiously, in my mind, I
was hoping it might be, like,
flaky sea salt, but it's a Pop-Tart.
I think it's more likely
to just be some icing.
Not too bad.
You also have a chocolaty
filling on that as well,
so it's kind of like three levels
of chocolate going on here.
Not too sweet either, actually.
All right, starting with
the frosted chocolate fudge.
All right, let's compare
this to what Harry got.
Chocolate on chocolate.
I know I'm just going
to state the obvious,
but this is, like, really
chocolaty and fudgy.
Seeing as we only have three Pop-Tarts,
I figured I'd try the
other ones too just to see
how they stack up against
the exclusive chocotastic.
So, this is our version
of hot fudge sundae.
Pastry-wise, looks kind of similar
to the chocolate one with
the chocolate pastry,
but then it has something more resembling
the strawberry icing.
I feel like this is probably
a slightly lazy attempt
to just kind of rehash
things they already have
into a new product. The
filling looks pretty similar
to the filling found on
the frosted chocotastic.
Slightly lighter in color,
so maybe they've gone for
more of a fudge vibe rather
than just straight chocolate.
I think with the combination
of the standard icing
and the slightly different
filling, this has more of a
well-rounded, balanced sweet flavor to it.
And, of course, the classic
strawberry Pop-Tart.
Obviously, visually this stands out
because they have not gone
for the chocolate pastry.
It's that very, kind of almost
alarmingly pale pastry color.
Pretty much the same icing, I think,
that they've used on the hot fudge sundae.
It's the classic for a reason.
It's just really good.
It's the blueberry. All
right, getting some fruit.
I wouldn't be able to
guess what fruit this was
just by looking at the outside. I mean ...
Here in the US so far,
one thing I've noticed,
they're really skimping on the filling.
I know it's, like, dusty, but
brown sugar cinnamon, beat up.
Ooh, this is, like, really smooth.
Also very dusty.
I honestly can't tell if the flavor
is the frosting or the jam.
Cherry. I mean, I feel like
this is a flagship one.
Aim's not so great over
there at the factory.
Already though, both on
this side and this side,
you can almost see the filling
coming out of it, right?
I'm starting to think that a
lot of the sweet fruit flavor
is coming from the frosting
and not the inside.
Chocolate chip.
All right. Already, this.
Could we get that sad trombone please?
It's like, so — it's
like a doctor's signature.
It's just, whoop! Right across it.
I can't read this. What does this say?
Oh, come — ugh, Pop-Tart.
Ooh, this really irritates me.
This really winds me up.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me with this.
Your mom or your school
or your work, whatever,
doesn't get Oreos,
they get the knockoff-brand
sandwich cookies,
and it's like, you'll eat them,
but you're like, "Ah, man.
Kind of wanted Oreos."
That's what this tastes like.
This tastes like a knockoff of an Oreo.
Frosted confetti.
Ugh. No, don't make me eat this.
Please don't make me eat this.
It's like just eating straight frosting.
Next up, frosted hot fudge sundae.
Breakfast is served.
This looks like an absolute nightmare.
Imagine eating this and going to school.
Totally phoned in, like, blah! Drizzle.
It's very sweet.
Oh, man.
A Pop-Tart s'mores. Yuelei's choice.
OK. It tastes like a s'mores.
You can see a little pocket
of marshmallow there.
This is the first dual
filling I think I've had,
or at least I've noticed.
And you know what?
I don't really like it.
I can't believe we only had one exclusive.
I feel like I'm really missing out
on some of those tasty American Pop-Tarts.
Joe, can I get some of those?
No worries, man. I got you.
Ah!
Thank you!
So, it looks like Joe
has kindly shared with me
some confetti cupcake Pop-Tarts,
the American version of the
hot fudge sundae Pop-Tarts,
and some frosted s'mores Pop-Tarts.
Frosted confetti.
I feel like Americans are just obsessed
with eating sprinkles
because it seems like every kind of brand,
whether it's chocolate, pastry,
will have a kind of confetti
cupcake, birthday cake flavor,
and Pop-Tarts are no exception.
American sprinkles look so much better
than British sprinkles.
I know it's because they
are using banned chemicals,
which we don't have over here.
We have to opt for natural alternatives.
But when it comes to baking,
they just hold their color so much better.
They look a lot more vibrant.
I kind of get why you guys are using it.
It doesn't give me any
pleasure to admit it,
but that is really tasty.
It's got almost a sort of
cake-batter taste to it, that filling.
So it kind of is like you're
eating a confetti cupcake,
or at least the batter
of a confetti cupcake.
In my left hand, I have a
British strawberry sensation Pop-Tart.
In my right hand, I have the American
frosted confetti cupcake one.
Just quickly wanted to point
out the color difference
because that is wild.
Next up is the American version
of the hot fudge sundae Pop-Tarts.
The American version of these
looks so much more fun than ours.
Size-wise, they look pretty much the same,
but the American one looks thicker.
The American one has
this white icing filling,
whereas in the UK I think they've gone for
more of a kind of fudgy chocolate filling.
The difference between these
two is kind of night and day.
The American one, better than
ours in pretty much every way.
I tasted this at first,
and I wasn't disappointed by it, per se.
But now that I've had the comparison,
direct comparison with the US,
this tastes like eating cardboard.
Finally, it's the
frosted s'mores Pop-Tart.
I gotta say, s'mores aren't
really a thing in the UK.
In the UK, we don't have graham crackers,
or, as we would pronounce
it, gray-ham crackers.
Shout out to my dad, Graham.
Yeah, there we go. There we go.
It's almost like a digestive biscuit.
These are pretty good.
This one looks maybe the scariest.
It's cookies and cream.
Whenever it's frosting
inside, I know I'm in trouble.
Yuck.
Don't give this to a child ever.
And most adults should also not eat this.
Grape. Grape?!
Fruit ones look how I think a
Pop-Tart is supposed to look.
They don't look that intimidating.
Grape is a really
popular flavor in the US,
but anyone in the US will tell you
that grape-flavored candy
doesn't really taste like grapes.
They somehow invented a grapelike flavor,
probably because grapes have
a weaker flavor, I think.
I'm not quite sure
exactly how it came to be,
but this tastes exactly like that
fake, imitation Bubblicious
bubble gum grape.
You know what I'm talking about.
A grape soda.
It's not bad. So far, all the fruit ones
are better than any of the other ones, so.
Yeah, Eggo.
How unnatural looking is this?
You know how you can take those classes,
I think they're called,
like, sip and paint,
where everyone paints the same
picture, the same still life
while they're sipping
wine with their friends?
This was the image they were painting,
and this is what they painted drunk.
This does not in any way
taste like an Eggo waffle.
I don't think it tastes
like waffles at all.
What ruins it is this frosting on here.
This is so sweet.
Raspberry.
I have a feeling this is
going to be a good one.
Yeah.
Top tier right here.
These were optimized for fruit filling.
Wild berry.
So is just the combination wild?
Or these were found in the wild?
Oh, no!
Alarm bells in my
caveman DNA is going off.
Do not eat. This is poisonous.
Do not eat. Warning. Warning.
Ancestors who ate this died.
Let's go against millions
of years of evolution
and bite into this woefully
bright-colored piece of,
I'm assuming, food.
We'll find out together.
With all the frosting that's on there,
it's actually not that sweet,
compared to the other fruit ones.
Play this part of the video
to the ambulance driver
when he asks what happened.
Boston cream.
Boston cream doughnut
is this doughnut right here,
if you haven't seen it.
You can't even tell where the cream is
compared to the color of the pastry.
What I'm about to say
will come as no surprise
to anyone watching this video,
but this one tastes completely artificial.
I know, right? Can you believe it?
On to the next, smaller pyramid.
Snickerdoodle.
Bland.
All right, let me look
at the unfrosted ones.
Unfrosted?
Unfrosted, we got strawberry,
brown sugar cinnamon,
and blueberry.
Unfrosted v. frosted.
I was complaining how sweet they were,
so maybe I'm more of an unfrosted guy
and I don't realize it,
but this looks weird.
This looks like an army ration.
This one is sweeter,
but not that much sweeter.
Don't you think with the
frosting it'd be night and day?
They're pretty similar.
Simply frosted harvest strawberry.
There you go. No artificial colors.
Color from natural sources.
Once again, regular strawberry Pop-Tarts.
They look pretty similar, right?
This one maybe has more frosting on it.
Wow. They taste exactly the
same as the artificial ones.
One other thing that
we wanted to talk about
was the
toasted-versus-untoasted-Pop-Tarts debate.
Now, people have been debating for years
whether it's better to
eat your Pop-Tarts toasted
or straight out of the packet.
I will say, in the UK,
this is less of a debate
because I feel like most
people are more likely
to toast their Pop-Tarts,
even though they are
safe to eat straight out of the packet.
However, we did notice that
on the American ones that Joe sent over,
there are some varying instructions,
which kind of confused us.
Apparently in the US,
you can microwave them,
which you're supposed to do
in bursts of three seconds
until they're hot enough to eat,
despite the fact that the British ones
explicitly tell you to not microwave them.
I'm assuming at some point
someone tried to microwave them
in the foil and was met
with a nasty surprise.
And also the American ones say
that you can freeze them
and eat them frozen.
Don't know why you would do that.
Frozen or semi-frozen pastry
does not sound like it would be nice.
But we're not here for
microwaved or frozen Pop-Tarts.
We're just going to heat a couple up
in the toaster oven and then compare them
to some untoasted Pop-Tarts
to see which ones I prefer.
All right. Toasty boy going in.
Let's see if we can rectify that.
Also, did you notice?
What is with Harry's giant toaster oven?
Look at the size of that thing!
Just get a regular toaster.
Ta-da!
Smells like toasted pastry.
Ah!
Hey!
Ooh, it is falling apart.
They're just breaking apart already.
The untoasted.
Yeah, toasted's way better.
The filling's more flavorful.
The crispiness of the pastry.
I just am too lazy to toast them.
So, this one on my right
is the untoasted version,
and on my left is the toasted version.
I gotta say, visually,
not a lot has changed.
I was hoping for a
little bit more browning
while it was in the oven.
Still not much of a snap from
the pastry, even when toasted.
But you can see that the
filling has slightly liquefied.
Really impressive that
they've actually managed
to create a pastry that doesn't just burst
and leak all of the filling
when it does get toasted.
I say impressive; probably
just uses a lot of chemicals.
Whereas when you compare
it to the untoasted one,
even when you kind of squish it down,
that filling is not going anywhere.
I do prefer the toasted
version, as I sort of expected.
I think the main difference for me
is actually in the filling.
Obviously, the flavor doesn't change a lot
when you toast it. It's
more the texture, I think.
Just the fact that it
does liquefy slightly
gives it a much more pleasant texture
when you actually bite into this thing.
Also in the US,
you can get something
called Pop-Tarts bites.
These guys right here.
I have strawberry, of course,
and confetti cake.
But you can also get brown sugar cinnamon,
frosted blueberry,
frosted chocolate fudge,
and strawberry banana.
I have no idea what these are.
No, these are not good.
Pop-Tarts also does
collabs with other brands.
For instance, there's a
Pop-Tarts Jeni's ice cream,
Coffee Mate has its own Pop-Tarts flavor,
and, of course, Pop-Tarts cereal.
It was originally called
Pop-Tarts Crunch, discontinued,
but they renamed it after
they brought it back.
In the UK, an eight-pack
of strawberry Pop-Tarts
costs you £2.99,
which is around $3.86.
That same box in the
US is $4.49, or £3.47,
a 16.3% increase in the US.
Oof! With the gouging!
Come on, guys.
It's not surprising to me
that Pop-Tarts are
really popular in the US.
We love a quick and convenient breakfast.
They have positioned
themselves in their advertising
as a more convenient
breakfast than cereal,
because you know how
inconvenient cereal is.
You gotta get the box and
the bowl and the spoon
and the milk and sit down and eat it.
Not Pop-Tarts. Cereal, too much work.
Pop-Tarts, way easier.
For me, the price increase
per portion makes sense
because I've always seen
Pop-Tarts as more of a treat
than an everyday breakfast food.
It was the sort of thing that
my mom might have let me had as, like,
a weekend-treat breakfast
if I had accompanied
on her weekly shop and
been very well behaved.
I will say that the marketing in the UK
explicitly doesn't brand
these as a breakfast food,
compared to something like cereal.
There is no mention
of the word "breakfast" anywhere on here.
They're just referred to
as "toaster pastries."
So I guess they could be
construed as more of a snack.
Is the lack of breakfast
talk the same in the US, Joe,
or are you guys a bit less shameless
about marketing desserts as
breakfast foods for children?
So, I originally thought
this was supposed to be
breakfast food, but
Harry makes a good point.
It doesn't say breakfast anywhere on here.
Even the box says you can get them
straight from the foil,
toasted, stacked, or frozen.
But they really are not saying
anything about breakfast.
So I went back and looked online.
In the '90s — I looked on YouTube.
I found a bunch of commercials
where they said it was
specifically for breakfast,
they even quote "part of
your complete breakfast."
So they did sometimes market them
as breakfast foods and then sometimes not.
And just for me, it sunk in that, yeah,
you have these for
breakfast in the morning
when you're in a hurry
to get to school or work.
Here is the nutritional information
for one strawberry Pop-Tart in the UK.
Let's be honest. They
come in packs of two.
So we're going to double those numbers
for a more accurate serving-size reading.
Thank you, Harry. Because in the US,
we go straight for the
two-tart serving size,
and here, our strawberry Pop-Tarts are ...
It looks like the UK numbers
are actually slightly
higher than those in the US,
so I guess that means we're winning?
Now, if calories are
your thing, in the US,
our cinnamon brown sugar
Pop-Tarts have the most.
400 per serving.
But wait!
The unfrosted
have even more calories.
410 per serving.
I don't know how that works either.
In 2021, somebody sued Kellogg's,
claiming that Pop-Tarts
contained way less strawberry
than what was presented on the packaging.
This case was ultimately
dismissed, as the judge said,
quote, "No reasonable
consumer could believe
from Kellogg's packaging
that the breakfast staple" —
Hey, breakfast! Perfect. OK.
"Contained only strawberries,
or more strawberries
than other ingredients
such as pears and apples."
The US packaging actually states that
the strawberry Pop-Tarts
contain 2% or less
of dried strawberries.
Here are all the ingredients
of a UK strawberry
sensation frosted Pop-Tart.
One thing to note is that the
gelatin used in a UK Pop-Tart
is explicitly labeled as "beef gelatin."
So unfortunately, this
means that British Pop-Tarts
are not suitable for vegetarians.
And here are all the ingredients
in a US strawberry Pop-Tart.
Doo, doo, doo, doo.
Of the many differences
between these two lists,
there are a few ingredients
we wanted to highlight here.
The first is TBHQ, or
tert-butylhydroquinone.
[beeping]
Leon: Tuberculosis headquarters, isn't it?
To be honest, quite.
[beeping]
This is a preservative which
is used to extend shelf life
or for added freshness,
as the US label states.
The FDA has put limits on
how much it can be used.
"TBHQ can't account for
more than 0.02 percent
of the oils in a food
because the FDA doesn't have evidence
that greater amounts are safe.
While that doesn't mean
that more than 0.02 percent is dangerous,
it does indicate that higher safety levels
haven't been determined."
Research has linked
TBHQ to health problems.
The National Library of Medicine
found vision disturbances
when it was consumed by humans,
as well as "liver enlargement,
neurotoxic effects, convulsions,
and paralysis in laboratory animals."
Pop-Tarts in the US also
contain synthetic food coloring
which are restricted in the UK,
specifically yellow 5, yellow 6, red 40,
because of their link to hyperactivity
and inattention in children.
Golly gee, I can't imagine why.
My brain is just going all over the place.
Another thing to note is that
the Pop-Tarts Joe sent me
are technically contraband items.
If you're working with the
police or the government
and you watch this, please
do not extradite Joe.
We need him for filming.
That's because the flour used
in US Pop-Tarts is bleached.
Bleaching flour has been banned
in the UK since the 1990s
over concerns about
potential health effects.
It also just seems unnecessary to me,
especially for something
that's going to be toasted
and darken in color anyway.
You guys just love putting
chemicals in your food
and seem to seize any
opportunity you can to do it.
Yeah, don't arrest me, but
he did ask me to send it.
So I will flip on the UK team in a second.
FBI, if you're watching,
I will wear a wire.
It was all Harry's idea.
I will help you take him down.
What?
I've been watching the current
season of "Love Island" UK.
So I'm like, "Are you
joking? Are you joking?
You're having a laugh.
Are you having a laugh?"
This is journalism, baby.
This is why we went to journalism school.
I didn't go to journalism
school, so I have an excuse.